Olivia is next in Alabama hi Olivia how
are you
hi I'm doing great how are you guys
today better than I deserve what's up so
I need help today finding a balance
between showing my husband respect in
his biblical role as the head of our
household and standing up I guess to say
against financial decisions that he's
wanting to make for family that I'm
really concerned about we are on baby
steps three B's and are on track to have
a good downpayment 20% down and by next
summer do we still have some time but he
is very adamant he tells me about
getting a 30-year mortgage
he's very familiar with your baby steps
and the financial plans that you keep
and I've sat down with him to share my
fears and concerns about the 30 year
versus a 15 and we ran the numbers and
we've seen you know in the long term how
much we can be saving with a 15-year
mortgage that he is still very much
against the higher monthly payments and
recently he's also been trying to get me
on board with doing one of those
first-time homebuyer programs where you
put 0% down and again I've talked with
him about my my concerns and fears with
that but now he's concerned that I am
seemingly unwilling to compromise on the
Dave Ramsey plan and so I don't really
know what to do going forward and it
kind of feels stuck okay to start with
it's not the Dave Ramsey plan it's just
you having a you have a viewpoint on
money and he has a different one you
know we're not going to allow the plan
or me to be the villain mm-hmm that
that's that's silly so but but the
argument is really he wants to do a 30
year and he wants to do a first time
homebuyer plan you want to do a 15
Translation
he's got house fever and want to buy a
bigger house than you are yeah that's
what this really is and there's more to
it than this isn't there Livia maybe not
maybe but yes I can hear it in your
voice
what is this shining a light on
I don't know how have you been married
it'll be a year next month this is our
first fight yeah I'm sorry like I can
hear the heartbreak in your voice I paid
with money
so what's it what's a disagreement
you'll have at your house
look like when you come to terms when
you come to collaborative terms together
you have other disagreements at the
house that on any number of things where
you're gonna eat no no you just don't
say so I'm gonna tell you something
crazy this is gonna be this can be a
great moment for you two
how you honor one another how you
respect each other and how you work
together on the other end of this deal
Dave she mentioned out of the gate this
idea of a head of household and
decisions I've seen that just tragically
abused over the years that sentiment
this idea of you know 5149 voting power
or I get the final say oh that what is
that what does that mean to you the well
it always comes up when it's being used
as a weapon
yes the only time it comes up and so you
know when you know Sharon is about a
strong-willed woman she'll run into you
and and very bright so I got there's two
problems right so not gonna be
manipulated and not gonna be told what
to do
and yet on occasion she because of other
through everything else is right [ __ ]
but I don't ever tell her I'm head of
the house that just really wouldn't work
to me house I guess what I get to be you
know right to me to him phrase head of
the household means it means I'm in
charge of serving it just serve
everybody I'll carry the burden I
to get to serve everyone here and the
problem is is that the people I'm
serving in the case of the Vue olivia is
that you don't feel like you're being
served you feel like he's being served
mmm in other words he's buying a house
that he wants that you feel like you
can't afford and so you know this is
more like a dictatorship than it is a
thing yeah and that's what's breaking
down here so what John said earlier
though is fabulous because this is if
you guys can sit down with your pastor
or a good marriage counselor and develop
some tools for handling conflict that
don't involve you automatically forgoing
your intelligence or your analysis of
something in the name of him being the
head of the household but instead he
actually is serving the household and
has made a very good case that that
instead of just getting his way but if
you can learn how to work through
conflict together here this could be a
real wonderful opportunity cuz you
haven't had enough conflict it sounds
like you agree on everything that's just
kind of ridiculous we don't agree on
anything we argue about everything but
we're hillbilly so that's okay we that's
how we express love but I'll tell you
this Olivia especially out of the gate I
mean I can hear the pain in your voice
now I know this is heavy they don't make
light of it this first but it is what is
challenging yeah but what's part of
what's heavy I think if I'm hearing you
right Olivia is you have this deep
desire there's two different principles
you're trying to adhere to at the same
time in a conflict with each other you
want to adhere to the principle of
honoring your husband's position and you
want to adhere to the principle that
your brain is telling you is the right
thing to do with money and those are
both things and so you know in other
words although a third one in there I
bet you feel a responsibility to be the
Peacekeeper in that house - oh and that
will way that will break a woman's soul
is
this-this-this felt need to make a peace
and to give up on herself and what she
knows to be right in service to let's
just not ruffle the feathers okay men
there's a wonderful book out that my
friend ed Grich did called love and
respect men have this huge desire for
respect women of the future desire to be
loved and he goes through and does a
wonderful job of unpacking that and but
respect is not acquiescing and parking
your brain at the door and it's not it's
not abandoning you know let's take it to
an extreme okay it's not this but let's
just say he decided I think doing
cocaine is really cool mhm
you know now are you supposed to respect
and go along with that in the name of
him being the head of the household no
that's that's asinine of course not okay
and so that's that's what that's the the
scenes of decision-making paradigm that
we're coming into here you've got a
thing where you're looking at him going
no that's dumb but I want to respect I'm
gonna respect you and give you the
dignity of this but I you know me going
along with you doing something dumb is
not honoring the position of head of
household alright Olivia your voice is
important I'm so glad he's lucky to have
married somebody with a brain you know
and somebody who's got a tender spirit
values your relationship what a gift you
are what a gift you are find somebody
that you can mediate that conversation
and blame it on some knuckleheaded
pseudo doc on the radio you can say hey
some guy said we need to go talk to
somebody help you navigate the tools the
help you navigate the the boundaries of
this first this first discussion this
first disagreement and values and if you
guys can develop a model for solving
conflict that doesn't always end in well
you have to go along cuz I'm here the
household then you're developed a cool
model you've won you've won that that's
worth it here that's more important than
a 15 year mortgage it the marriage the
marriage inquiries and challenges only
get more complex from here I wish this
is the hardest one night we got books on
the bookstore Kelly still if we got them
in the I think we got them I think we
got them in here if we do cinder one
love and respect if not if we don't have
melibea
find out you just go buy one but if we
got one we'll send you one we used to
carry them in the bookstore because our
wonderful marriage book